Hey everyone, it's Mike and I want to
share with you how three traders in my
community walked away with over $2,000,
$9,000, $6,000 from setups shared and
learned in strategic traders. I'm going
to show you the exact setup so you can
spot the next one. Here's the first
setup. It's delta divergence at the low
of the day followed by exhaustion on the
pullback. Says trader got long uh crude
oil 10 contracts around the 55.89 area
and sold them out around 5610.
Setup number two. So, this trader took
out $9,000 in about 2 minutes based off
the verticality signal, the volume
pressure spike, the bid ass momentum
signal, right? You can see at this point
he was over $95,000 in the money. Trade
setup number three, this was in ultra
bonds, right? And he says even here, he
says you can see it quite regularly. The
low of the day, which was equal to
around yesterday's low, you got a three
time open point of control and
accumulation distribution in a row
signaling bullishness. At this point,
you see on his chart, he was over $6,875
in the money. Now, the best part is
these are just a few of the trade setups
being discussed and shared inside
strategic traders every day. Not just by
me, but by other successful traders.
For over 20 years, I was a professional
trader at places like JP Morgan,
Commerce Bank, and Cargill. But here's
what's even more important. Over the
last 10 years, I've coached over 1,000
traders on how to trade order flow
successfully. A few months ago, I
created strategic traders community so
traders can interact and better
understand orderflow analysis and build
their own edge in the market. I realized
in trading that not everyone makes it,
but the ones who follow my tried and
trueue methods, they see consistent
results. So, I created the strategic
traders environment.
And the traders in my community
aren't professionals with years of
experience. Many of them started exactly
where you are right now, frustrated with
traditional analysis that doesn't work.
But the ones who learned order flow,
they've gone from breaking even or just
losing money to hitting consistent $500
to $5,000 days. And in the past 3
months, many traders are now
successfully implementing these exact
strategies as well as sharing strategies
that work for them. The amount of
trading knowledge they share is
unbelievable. I'm even learning new ways
to trade and I've been trading since the
1990s. You know, in this post, a trader
talks about the order flows verticality
and volume pressure spike setup. He says
every day he's seeing um you know, up to
10 clear setups at
generating $1,250
of profit per trade on five contracts.
Imagine $1,250
and you're getting 10 setups a day. You
do the math, you know. So, here's
another setup that's being shared, the
AVA with the retest, right? You see on
this chart, traders over $3,000 in
profit. Here's another one. This is in
the Euro currency. You know, it's
trading 10 contracts. Traders up over
$6,000.
Strategic traders members are getting
funded as well using orderflow setups
they learned inside. They are not
exceptional traders. They're just normal
people who have finally understood what
institutional buyers and sellers are
doing. They all have one thing in
common. They stopped guessing and
started reading the actual order flow
and price action. You see this trader
passed his fourth evaluation in 4 days.
It's another trader passed three
evaluations in 10 days. It's another
trader talking about the setup that he
uses to pass his Apex evaluation. You
can see he's sharing all the trades he
took with his entry and exit. Now,
here's what I see happening with most
traders, right? They're using price
action alone. They're following the
crowd. They're trading based on what
they think should happen next instead of
what the order flow and price action is
telling them will happen next. And
that's why they lose. The successful
traders, they're reading order flow and
combining it with price action. They're
seeing aggressive buyers and sellers.
They're watching volume at specific
price levels. They understand the
auction. That's their edge.
Our traders aren't just scalping ES
futures. There are traders consistently
profitable on NQ, NASDAQ, you know, the
MEES micros, CL, crude oil, and even
crypto futures using the same order flow
and price action principles. Different
markets, same edges. Last week alone, a
trader in the community shared his
results of hitting um his $1,000
target using a setup he learned in
strategic traders. Talks about the setup
here and he says, you know, I tested it
today, worked beautifully. 1,00 1K
target hit.
So, Strategic Traders is a community
where I teach you everything that I've
learned about order flow and price
action analysis. We have weekly group
coaching calls where we walk through
live charts, analyze real market data,
break down exactly what the order flow
is showing us, and discuss how to turn
that into profitable setups. You get
access to my complete course library,
footprint charts, delta analysis,
imbalance trading, barby bar analysis,
and tape reading everything. You also
get community support where you can ask
questions and get feedback on your
charts and learn directly from traders
who are actively using these strategies
right now.
But you want to know the real secret
sauce. It's what the other members are
sharing with each other. You don't get
better trading by yourself in a vacuum.
You need real interaction with other
traders to bounce ideas off to work
together to create new winning
strategies. There is a saying, iron
sharpens iron. And by surrounding
yourself with successful traders, your
path is up. Now, you might be thinking,
will this work for me? I'm new to
trading. The answer is yes. If you're
willing to learn, you might be
wondering, is this too expensive?
Normally, it costs $147 a month to join
Strategic Traders, but for a limited
time, you get lifetime access for just a
small one-time payment. Just one
payment, and you're getting
grandfathered in. No hidden fees, no
upsells. You get full access to
everything. Trade setups, courses,
calls, and most importantly, the
community.
Here's a trader. He says, "I can't quite
believe how quickly my trading has
improved since joining here.
Thanks for putting it all together and
keep up with the short videos. Really
helpful and appreciated. Now, the market
doesn't wait and neither should you. The
traders who started learning orderflow 3
months ago are now understanding what is
happening in the market. But they had to
act first. The window of opportunity is
always now. So join strategic traders
community right now. Get involved in the
weekly calls. Introduce yourself in the
community. Start watching the course
content today. Start winning. And I'll
see you on the inside. Just go to
strategictraders.com.
I'll see you there.